december 10 2021 i'm jessica rosenthal
tomorrow marks a day many of us will
never forget september 11th 20 years ago
was a day of loss fear and terror but
also incredible heroism and even unity
these men and women continue to give
their lives for us
and we have to make sure our kids and
our grandkids
know
that
freedom
is not free
i'm dave anthony 20 years after 9 11
it's still a story that gives us chills
the heroes who fought back on flight 93.
they bonded together to be clumped
become one cohesive unit
and gave their lives so we can continue
to live our lives like it's september
10 2001.
and i'm brian kilmeade i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
tomorrow marks 20 years since 9 11 and
if you were old enough to remember that
day you probably remember where you were
that sinking feeling the shock how it
changed you how it changed us
president george w bush informed the
country shortly after it happened
september 11 2001 and the following
audio is from that day two airplanes
have crashed
into the world trade center
in an apparent terrorist attack on our
country
[Applause]
we had a very loud blast explosion
we looked up
and the building literally began to
collapse before us
and the people who knocked these
buildings down
will hear all of us soon
so much has happened in the following
years new rules for flying new laws like
the patriot act but this segment today
is about what mr rogers once said quote
when i was a boy and i would see scary
things in the news my mother would say
to me look for the helpers you will
always find people who are helping frank
ziller's brother steven was a
firefighter who rushed to the twin
towers to help that day and after he
died ziller became a helper himself
starting the tunnel to towers foundation
paying the mortgages for families who've
lost first responders and u.s service
members
siller began walking from the pentagon a
few weeks ago all the way to new york
where he is ending his journey tomorrow
at ground zero in honor of his brother i
dwell on a lot while i'm walking i i
find it so therapeutic
um to do that and walking has always
been a big part of my life and of course
walking into new york now after i've
walked
525 miles so far wow i have only 10 more
miles to go
and um but i'm leaving the two miles
plus
uh through the tunnel of course for the
anniversary of september 11th where i
retrace what my brother did 20 years ago
when he ran through the brooklyn battery
tunnel with 60 pounds of fire gear on
his back and gave up his life
so yes as i'm coming closer to new york
it's getting very emotional it's been
emotional the whole way but now it's
it's almost overwhelming
can can you tell us about your brother's
journey that day i know you've recounted
it time and time again but it is
important for us to remember how
our first responders responded i mean in
particular your brother wasn't even on
duty right no he was just finished his
tour duty at night uh he worked at squad
one in brooklyn he actually was on his
way home to play golf with myself my
brother george my brother russ the four
brothers gonna play golf but he heard on
the radio scandal that the towers were
hit
so he turned his truck around went back
to his firehouse
and uh got his gear and he drove to the
mouth of the brooklyn battery tunnel
it was closed for security reasons there
were cars abandoned they didn't want any
more cars in there so
an
eyewitness uh
account tells me he came to a screeching
halt
and
threw his gear on as quickly as possible
and then uh and then started jogging
into the into the tunnel
and you know i didn't know on 9 11 that
that he had done this you know our
family we didn't know that he had done
this
um but it didn't surprise us because you
know this is exactly what you just said
this is what firefighters do our first
responders are men and women in uniform
they run right towards the danger when
everyone else is running away or
they save people you know that's
biggest rescue mission ever was uh
saving twenty thousand plus lives
out of those towers on nine 911 my
brother was part of that but while doing
so he gave his life so that you know
these terrorists killed 2977
americans and they were murdered uh my
brother
gave his life on that day along with the
343 firefighters and 60 police officers
and other great heroes that decide to go
back or run into that building and those
buildings and
save other people's lives so we were so
proud of what he did we started the
foundation his honor called the tunnel
to towers foundation
i want to ask more about that but tell
me about your plan on on saturday your
your plan if i have this right is to
retrace his steps
exactly uh so
early in the morning on saturday i'll be
at the mouth of the brooklyn battery
tunnel on the brooklyn side
i'll uh be uh with my family uh with
some of my siblings and uh my wife i'll
be with my children uh some of four of
my six grandchildren will be doing it
the other two a little too young
to do it
and we will be walking through that
tunnel um to commemorate and to honor
what my brother did 20 years ago and to
bring it to a close my
537 mile journey uh that i started on
august 1st at the pentagon and i've
walked to shanksville pennsylvania and
now i'm back in uh new york and they'll
be finishing as i said on the morning of
september 11th and to honor all these
great heroes but more certainly to honor
my brother and what he did 20 years ago
so i can't imagine how emotional it's
going to be i think that you know i mean
i i'm going through that tunnel
with sneakers on
he ran through that tunnel
with his gear on and and his uh uh he
didn't have sneakers on you know that
and
and uh he had 60 pounds of gear on and
when i come out of the tunnel i'm going
to be looking at the freedom tower but
he looked at the twin towers
that was horrific site where you saw
the fire line where
you know
these great people that are trapped
above the fire line they had a choice to
burn i hate to say this but this is the
truth and we always should just say the
truth the burn or the jump and many of
them
jumped and and it was just a horrific
scene uh so he you know he wanted to
make a difference
all his life he want to make a
difference and
that's why i'm doing this walk i want to
bring to light what my brother did 20
years ago and the selfless act that he
did and so many others and i think i i i
i know
uh by doing this walk for almost 42 days
that it's drawn a lot of attention to
the great heroes of 911 and one of them
was my brother
yeah wow it's
heavy to think of all those images that
day
frank if if time heals it can also fade
our memories of what happened um i know
the security picture in afghanistan
right now certainly bringing
back a lot of this for for many of us
but what is the best way
to talk about 9 11 to younger
generations i mean you just mentioned
you've got grandkids i have young
children
what what are you how do you broach the
subject when you
tell them about it
so i think uh you know i addressed
um seventh and eighth graders uh from a
school where i went to
uh on staten island and my brother went
there and my siblings and my kids and so
it's been a big part of that plus
sacrament parish and part of my life for
68 years
and um i spoke to them and i said you
guys are old enough to know what went on
you you you you should know what
happened on september 11 2001 and if
your parents aren't telling you they
should be telling you so go ask them and
you know what you should ask him you
should ask him to bring you
to the pentagon
to shanksville pennsylvania and to
ground zero to the museum and you can
find out all what it went on uh 20 years
ago i said because you know what we
don't want another 911 to happen and if
you forget about what happened
you forget about your past
you're doomed and as a country we would
be doomed
um and to see what just went on in
afghanistan that we couldn't get out all
our american brothers and sisters
and and we didn't have the proper
structure to protect our military that
were there and we lost 13 more great
heroes
it is
i talked to gold star widows and they
are distraught that is the word
distraught on how we uh
how we handled our our
final engagement in afghanistan i mean
there was a
anybody could have done a better job i
don't know who was making the decisions
uh i blame it on the president but
there were many people around him that
gave him very bad advice
and uh it's just
it's just mind-boggling but nonetheless
these men and women continue to give
their lives for us
and we have to make sure our kids and
our grandkids
know
that
freedom
is not free now that you've heard that
everyone's heard that line before right
freedom isn't free well they got to know
what what that means and what that means
is that people die all the time for us
and and and we better take care of them
as a country and the tunnel the tablet
foundation we made a promise and this is
the promise that if you go out and you
go to serve your country or your
community and you give your kids a kiss
goodbye and you don't come home
we're going to take care of your family
that's left behind we're going to give
them a mortgage-free home
and
we're proud to make that that promise
and that commitment but nonetheless uh
american families have to tell their
kids uh everything that that went on
then and about the seven 000 men and
women in uniform they gave their lives
ever since to protect us
you've done a lot of interviews leading
up to saturday what have you not been
asked that you want people to know about
in this moment
i i really
don't know you're right i have done a
lot of interviews and
i i'm just but i'm i don't mind doing
them because anytime i get to speak
about my brother and talk about these
great heroes is always uh it's it's why
i do it it's
i don't want my brother's final acts to
ever be forgotten i don't want what
these guys did
20 years ago ever be forgotten i don't
want these heroes that die every day for
us to be forgotten and uh so you know
i don't mind doing the interviews but
it's important that people actually do
something
people got to do something
you know they can't just be moved to say
oh what a story oh
it's beautiful oh this one gave so much
oh my god we got to do something
and the total powers foundation we made
a conscious decision my brothers and
sisters when we started this that we
weren't going to stay in a very dark
place
that we wanted to just do good saint
francis of assisi said brothers and
sisters while we have time let us do
good well you know what what we're doing
is good and you do heal that way but we
did something
to help other people and i think you
just can't who in our and say how sad
look how bad
you know look look what they gave up no
you got to do something and they could
we want people to join us on doing good
and it's as simple as that so i'll do as
many
uh interviews and as possible to make
sure that we take care of these great
heroes
frank ziller thank you so much for your
time appreciate it
thank you god bless have a great day
[Music]
this is brian kilmeade with your fox
news commentary coming up
there are nearly 3 000 stories to tell
about 9 11 for every one of the victims
killed that day in 2001 among the most
compelling come from a big hole in the
ground in a field near shanksville
pennsylvania from my estimates i would
guess it was probably about 20 to 15
feet
long and probably about 10 feet long or
10 feet wide it's where the last of the
four hijacked planes crashed killing all
33 passengers and seven crew members
they did nothing to provoke
or deserve
the deliberate act of murder
that al qaeda carried out
one of the lessons of 9 11
is that evil is real
and so is courage that was former
president george w bush dedicating a
flight 93 national memorial and it's
from there
we get to hear the audio of just how
compelling and chilling this 20 year old
story still is what else does it appear
to be that he's probably eight thousand
feet he's behind us at only about a
thousand feet above it i advise you stay
away from that aircraft go north as fast
as you can well then air traffic control
also asked that other pilot who was
nearby if you can report what he's doing
sir uh it looks like he's rocking his
wings
which might have been the very moment
the terrorist hijackers were battling
the passengers who fought back they all
knew what was going on some used the
plane's earphones to call home linda
grondland called her sister i'm on
united 93 and it's been hijacked by
terrorists who say they have a bomb
apparently they have flown a couple of
planes into the world trade center
already it looks like they're going to
take this one down as well
hopefully i just wanted to say i love
you
and
i'm gonna meet you
imagine coming home to that voicemail
todd beamer was talking to a united
agent about the plan to fight back and
his famous last words she heard was to
the other passengers
okay
let's roll
air traffic control heard some of that
chaos and flight recorders also picked
up the sounds of passengers crashing
through the cockpit door and the
struggle with the terrorist pilot who
ultimately flew the plane straight into
the ground which is still horrifying 20
years later
yes
it it really is and actually today is
kind of a little harder than usual ken
nackey's brother was on flight 93. we
spoke to him on thursday which would
have been joey's birthday
it would have been 62 today
so he was 42
the day it happened
take us back
did you even know he was flying that
morning
no i did not and it was rare for him to
fly for work you know i can probably
count on one hand the amount of times
that he had to travel for work
you know and he was he was a director of
warehousing for uh kb toys so he could
always you know delegate it to someone
else if they needed something taken care
of
but um you know a shipment a large
shipment of toys went missing
and you know my dad kind of raises
saying our word is our bond so he
decided just to try to make a day trip
that uh he was going to fly out
you know talk to the company and then
turn around and fly home on the red high
so he only be gone today
and he was actually
celebrating his uh 42nd birthday
when he made a slider arrangements
so last minute trip
and obviously he picks flight 93
he's on board
did you
when did you find out that he was on
that flight it was later in the in the
morning you know fight 93 you know
actually crashed here in western
pennsylvania at 103.
um
i'm actually back then i was a part of
the canine unit with the baltimore
county police department and i actually
got called out to handle
a uh a bomb threat at an airport
and uh so
it's customary for us i knew about um
the plane striking the world trade
centers i actually watched the second
plane on the tv hit the world trade
center and then we got a request to go
out so
so you're thinking obviously here it is
911. america is under attack and you
like all of us horrified and and you're
and you're ready to go to work not
knowing what you're going to find right
yeah it's you know it's unfortunately
it
had to be kicked into his business as
usual you know i mean i had to provide
the services to the citizens of
baltimore county
in the end though nothing
materialized where you were going right
no actually we were able it took about
an hour and a half to clear the building
so
i did not know about flight 93 actually
uh at all when i went into the building
because when you go in you have to turn
off all your radios
your communication stuff so you don't i
think transmitting your cell phones your
police radios so when i got back out and
put my dog back in the truck and i
turned everything on you know my phone
immediately starts ringing and
it's my wife and she says hey i've been
trying to reach you for a while your dad
just called and he says he believes
joey's
on one of the flights
and at that time i'm thinking only three
flights i'm thinking why would joey be
you know what i mean at the pentagon or
the same you know just goes through your
mind like saying he never flies right
there so you so your origin your first
thought is that's not that's not true
uh yeah my first mind went right for me
went right into denial i said how can
that be and then you start asking all
those questions that you know your my
wife didn't have the answers to
that that quick you know what i mean my
mind's just racing like saying
has you know any of the airlines called
mom and dad or had they called his wife
you know what i mean has anybody reached
out to him has you know has
no one so it was kind of like
that void
and it's like i say it seems like a
lifetime but you know i mean you just
mind just starts wandering and like i
said i went from going into denial
thinking now joey never flies to as i'm
now going to my next call for service
that
now
something in the pit of my stomach and
the hair on the back of my neck are just
tingling like saying
you know something's wrong something's
missing and i think if you have
like a close-knit family you understand
what i'm saying i think we all know with
something in our lives or in our family
is a miss
yeah
and then
you start learning more about what
happened
on that flight
a lot of passengers had called people
from the plane
did joey make any phone calls
no and and and i really knowing him as
well as i do i don't think he would
and and
because
you know he was he was somewhat but a
very he could make decisions quickly and
he was kind of a man of action
and also
knowing what we know now 20 years later
is only x amount of phone calls can
could be made at a time on the flights
at that time there's you know that the
system only allows x amount of calls to
go out at any time
and and you know the good thing about
flight 93 is they had the time you know
they took off like 46 minutes late so
they had
they were afforded the time to where
they could actually after the hijacking
make phone calls to gain the information
knowing that their plane was going to be
used as a weapon
so
how courageous is that knowing that
you're wet your your flight is going to
be used at a weapon
and then all 40 of them muster up that
inner strength that we all have and
saying hey
this is not going to happen on my watch
not today not tomorrow
not never
so you you believe you believe that your
brother would have been among those
trying to get into that cockpit trying
to stop it
oh no doubt i i think it took but it
takes the strength of all 40 of them
for it to be successful
joey
could is probably had the biggest heart
of anyone i ever met forever knew
but he also had that little switch
inside you that can turn from your best
friend to your worst nightmare in
probably about a nano second he was an
avid bodybuilder and uh our dad always
taught us early on in life
that
always prepare for the worst and hope
for the best
kind of mentality my dad you know served
time in the military at the end of uh in
between world war ii and the korea war
so you know what i mean he had that kind
of discipline in him and he shared it
with us as kids
have you gone to the shanksville
memorial have you gone to the site
oh i've gone to the site more times than
i can remember i got fortunate i was
actually nominated
to be one of the 15 federal advisory
commissioners that actually oversaw the
design the
and the construction of the flight 93
national memorial so i have i've walked
it uh i walked every inch of the 2500
acres
of the memorial over time
when was the first time you went to the
site where the plane crashed
september 13 2001.
so
why was it still smokey was it still
smoldering
yes i actually was uh
brought out to the
since i was a police officer at the time
they actually brought me out
days earlier than everyone else
i went out there on september 13th by
myself and the pennsylvania state police
took me out there while uh they're
actually still
searching the site
must still be burned in your memory what
you saw oh yeah the whole day that whole
week is you know
for me it's like um i can remember like
it was yesterday
so now we're 20 years later
obviously the memories haven't faded
a lot of people don't even know you know
20 years later much about 9 11 what do
you tell people about 911
you're right you figure there's probably
more what 77 million people probably
have been born in the last 20 years
and uh but yeah so there's there's
you know you think about it there's 20
year olds that were not even born
you know for the events and and i think
the greatest story that comes out of
flight 9ds3 is how
40
individuals from all different walks of
life and ages and professions and life
experiences were able to put everything
aside
and have just enough love and respect
for each other to where
they bonded together to become become
one cohesive unit
and gave their lives so we can continue
to live our lives like it's september
10 2001.
i think that's such a powerful story
and they did everything that day on that
flight within 30 minutes
so they were able you know get over that
initial shock of the hijacking you know
i mean that and that stress i didn't
realize okay
people are making phone calls gathering
information i believe people are
protecting the people who are making the
phone calls from the you know from the
watchful eyes of the terrorists you know
i mean they were all herded back into
the rear of the plane
so you're thinking they gained
information
you know put it all together realized
that this was going to be used as a
weapon
and then came up with a plan
voted on a plan
and and then they decided to execute it
it's an amazing story 20 years later
it really is and and and we uh thank you
for joining us and again sorry for uh
the loss of your brother joey ken nackey
thank you very much for joining us
thank you very much for having me
[Music]
hey it's brett larsen inviting you to
download and listen to the new daily fox
on tech podcast there's part of a
colorful late 90s imac on mars it's an
idea that seems a lot like kickstarter
called build it subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you get your podcasts
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
there's a famous quote by mr rogers you
know of mr rogers neighborhood that
seems worth remembering this week it was
something his mother used to say to him
when there was a catastrophe on the news
or in a movie she'd say quote look for
the helpers i was reminded of that when
i recently talked to jessica dulong
she's a former chief engineer on new
york city fire boat john jay harvey that
served at ground zero on september 11
2001.
minutes after the towers fell a call
went out for all available boats and in
her book saved at the seawall stories of
the september 11th boat lift jessica
says at least 800 mariners and 150 boats
answered that call sailing yachts dinner
cruise boats
everything that you can think of
everything that floated was marshaled to
this rescue the helpers if you will
they worked tirelessly that day taking
people from lower manhattan to safety
across the hudson river docking in new
jersey
jessica says that's what sets those
mariners apart
even if you're going to rescue people
the first time off the island you have a
boat full of people you drop them off
you tie up and you are safely away from
disaster
and what you need to do is you need to
make a choice to turn your boat around
and over and over again head straight to
the catastrophe that's unfolding that
nobody knows what's happening next we
don't know if it's the end of the world
we don't know if this is the beginning
of so much worse right and over and over
again these mariners
pointed their bows
back to the island on fire
and they did so but over and over again
with a choice but when i spoke with them
it wasn't a choice i mean they could say
okay yeah i guess it was a choice but it
was not because who they were is who we
all can be
which is
with the capacity to just reach into
ourselves and know that when other
people need help we help this is
actually who we are before we get in our
own way this is who we are boats came
from everywhere even those that weren't
passenger vessels they scrambled to load
people on board to get them off the
island it was the largest maritime
evacuation in history even larger than
the boat lift at dunkirk nearly half a
million people were rescued by boat that
day in lower manhattan jessica says it's
the stories of these acts of heroism
that she wants people to know about we
need the narratives of september 11th
that tell the whole story and they're
all the stories of the the sort of
firefighter rushes in and the heroism
that's typified in our normal ideas of
what a hero is but there are other
stories of just everyday people who are
we know from disaster research the first
first responders almost always are just
people just everyday people with no
professional responsibility the helpers
in new york tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade and this is the fox news
rundown my take on 9 11 20 years later
well 20 years ago i was lucky enough to
be on the air at the time when that
horrific day took place when the plane
hit the building uh while we were on the
air and right after the second one at
906 did just the same and this year had
the opportunity to go to shanksville and
see flight 93 where it crashed and what
those brave men and women did when they
were needed most or else the whole
capitol building would have exploded
because it would have been the fourth
plane the only one not to reach its
target having said all that i'm very
heartened by the fact that we go down
and see a memorial like no other that is
reminiscent and worthy of the people
that gave their lives that day i think
that's great the fact that downtown has
been rebuilt shows that new york would
take a little bit while but eventually
get it right what i find really
disheartening is what you find
disheartening where we're right now in
afghanistan where president united
states would decide to lose a war and
humiliate a nation that 200 plus years
of success yeah there's been struggles
there's been some doubts there's been
battles we'd want to have back but never
in american history have we felt such
defeat defeat thrust upon ourselves and
a gift a gift of afghanistan to our arch
enemies the taliban who stand for
nothing but 7th century terror and
a promise that they'll come back to hit
us someday right here again are we ready
for that challenge i'm brian kilmeade
and that's my take for the fox news
rundown
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown saturday marks
20 years since the september 11th
terrorist attacks the deadliest foreign
attack on u.s soil chairman and ceo of
the tunnel to towers foundation frank
ziller walking over 500 miles to
remember the nearly 3 000 people killed
that day including his brother stephen a
new york city firefighter he discusses
the importance of his journey and what
he wants the younger generation to know
about that dark day in history
remembering the flight that fought back
baltimore county police detective ken
nackey joins the rundown to talk about
his brother joey who died aboard united
airlines flight 93 and reflects on the
bravery of passengers who took on
hijackers trying to crash the jet in
washington d.c plus commentary by
co-host to fox and friends and host of
the brian kilmeade show brian kilmeade
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we take a deeper look at
the stories important to you you could
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to fox news podcast dot
com